bonjour j'espère que vous allez super
bien moi mon nom c'est jeremy maclin
levandowski développe pas longtemps je
suis allé au bowling est arrivé d'abord
il y avait deux il y avait deux côtés
donc tout d'abord du premier côté à la
gauche
c'étaient des jeunes de 10 à 13 ans
peut-être qu'ils jouaient et j'ai tendu
mon oreille pour que je suis curieux et
je voulais écouter ce qui se disait
est ce que j'ai entendu malheureusement
ça comme un peu fait saigner les
oreilles parce que ce que j'entendais
c'était terrible c'était que des
insultes quelqu'un manque son coup
c'était en tes poches à et continuer le
même des vieux saint loup jeudi leur
pote vise toujours à côté une quelqu'un
réussit son coup un même chose au tulle
mairie de postes c'est juste la chance a
refait les dons c'était bon ça a comme
un peu fait mal à l'orgueil et la après
de l'autre côté il y avait des personnes
âgées les personnes âgées logtemps
dumont oreilles pour écouter ce qui se
disait
et on prend les deux mêmes situations
donc quelqu'un rendent rate son coup
c'était positif au continues comme ça tu
veux la voir
et quelqu'un réussit son coup ya si tu
es le meilleur tu vas gagner et vous
savez à quoi ça m'a fait penser ça à la
confiance en soi parce que adolescents
souvent même si on essaie de démontrer
le contraire avec nos actions souvent on
manque de confiance parce que justement
ce qu'on fait c'est que on laisse
l'opinion des autres du monde autour de
nous de notre entourage déterminer notre
propre jugement envers nous mêmes et
c'est ça justement c'est on laisse
l'opinion des gens déterminés ce qui
sera pour nous une fierté ou non c'est
au monde remonte pas nous fierté aux
autres pour avoir leur opinion
non étant donné que l'opinion des autres
c'est ce qui compte le plus c'est leur
opinion qui vient déterminer qui laisse
déterminer ce qui sera une fierté ou non
pour nous
enfin on est influençable tout le monde
est comme ça enfin tout le monde est
influençable et effectivement en forme
tout le monde est influençable et
excusez moi vous pouvez regarder ma
pause le temps que mon texte me
reviennent donc c'est ça donc enfants
tout le monde est influençable you
pratiquement aucune exception des
parents est un pote le dessin tu leur en
montrer
mais c'est quoi ce parce que ton dessin
y est mauvais les poches des poches est
un autre exemple tu coules ton examen
tes parents ta gueule bencsik ben c'est
quoi ce parce que t'as pas d'avenir et
tes poches et leur je sais que ça paraît
totalement absurde et vous riez mais un
enfant lui un jeune enfant
c'est comme ça que lui il perçoit ya pas
de nuances
le cerveau humain en moyenne fini de se
développer vers approximativement 21 ans
est selon moi c'est ce qui explique
pourquoi on a tendance à suivre ce que
pensent les autres comme un morceau de
castets le tu vois il veut aller
rejoindre les autres castings pour
former son image mais c'est ça un enfant
il s c'est ma journée aujourd'hui
ouais donc c'est ça donc un enfant lui
y'a pas de nuances parce que un père ou
une mère un parent qui dénigrent son
enfant et qui dit des paroles
désagréables inacceptable et inadéquate
c'est ce qui forge en partie en majeure
partie comment l'enfant lui vaut voir
devant le miroir quand il se regarde est
ce qu'on a envie que ce qu'ils soient
face à l'enfant lorsqu'il se regarde
dans le miroir est ce qu'on a envie que
ce soit un homme confiant qui fait face
à ses peurs ou alors un vaurien renfermé
sur lui même dans le coin du mur qui
braille en position foetale
mais justement le comportement des
parents et des gens autour de lui c'est
ce qui laisse déterminer sa donc pour
contrer ça ma solution you rien de
justement c'est un peu banal ça peut
paraître banal et il n'y a rien
d'exceptionnel c'est juste consent
courage qu'on laisse pas l'opinion des
autres détruire notre orgueil et notre
intérieur jusque on s'encourage qu'on
s'entraide et qu'on dise aux autres le
positif est qu'on le fasse savoir aux
autres parce que parmi vous parmi nous
et un futur psychologue un futur
athlètes un futur enseignant un avocat
toutes les disciplines que vous faire
réfléchir et chacun d'entre nous avoir
un impact chacun d'entre nous de manière
minime ou non allons changer le monde de
notre discipline
chacun d'entre nous avons un impact et
il faut justement dire aux autres
essayer de faire découvrir aux autres
c'est quoi l'impact qui vont avoir sur
le monde
j'aimerais vous poser une petite
question avant de m'égarer de m'éclipser
penser à la dernière fois où quelqu'un
c'est vraiment assis devant vous
quelqu'un s'assied devant vous et à
essayer de vous faire savoir tout le
négatif que vous aviez quand tu fais si
j'aime pas ça quand tu fais ça ça
m'énerve quand tu fais ça ça m'a grèce
et que ça vous fait quelque chose
maintenant ainsi de comparer ça avec la
dernière fois que quelqu'un s'est assis
devant vous et un prix un ton doux calme
et vous se dit tout le positif lui qui
avait envie d extraordinaire et
confiance je peux réussir tu es super et
qui était vraiment sincère maintenant
comparer ces deux extrémités et lequel
arrive plus souvent est question
supplémentaire
posez vous la question pourquoi
parce que le succès se trouve pas en
haut de la montagne mais bien dans leur
façon de gravir la montagne
et si vous avez tendance à plus vous
pencher vers le négatif des choses mon
message pour vous c'est le suivant
changé changeons notre perspective des
choses
encourageons nous parce que une personne
qui fait ça dans le monde sa robe pas
tant d'impact mais toute une population
7.5 milliards de personnes qui
s'entraident et qui se donne confiance
c'est ce qui nous unit alors changé et
changeons notre perspective et le monde
sera plus positif et tout le monde aura
confiance et découvrira qu'à l'impact
qu'il aura sur la société
merci
[Applaudissements]